jean marc sylvestre bonjour alors on
sait que les états unis auraient pré
acheté des doses à sanofi ce qui a été
mollement démonter par l'entreprise la
chaîne
elle promet de mettre à disposition du
monde entier son vaccin et l'europe dans
tout cela a du mal à exister on a
l'impression que ça ressemble un petit
peu à une guerre mondiale c'est une
guerre vont dire un enjeu et sanitaires
bien sûr parce que les pays d confine
progressivement aujourd'hui mais le sib
le virus lui continue de circuler on
sera bien obligé de se protéger tant
qu'il n'y aura pas de traitement
efficace ou mieux tant qu'il n'y aura
pas ce vaccin la disposition de tout le
monde cette pandémie est un mondial
l'enjeu du vaccin et mondial
sept milliards d'êtres humains sont
concernés ils vont avoir besoin de se
protéger donc derrière ya évidemment un
enjeu économique et financier
considérable parce qu'on aura besoin de
milliards de doses le problème c'est que
ça coûte très cher tout ça ça coûte très
cher de mettre au point un vaccin au bas
mot ça coûte plus de 2 milliards de
dollars en moyenne parce que la mise au
point la validation du vaccin
sa fabrication aussi demandent plusieurs
années de travail de recherche parce
qu'il faut être absolument sûr qu'il
fonctionne et ce qui ne fonctionne bien
et bien on ne vendra qu'une injection
par personne
il ya donc des médicaments pour les
labos qui sont beaucoup plus rentables
que les que les vaccins les industriels
les états prennent aujourd'hui des
risques qui sont très importants parce
que finalement il y aura sans doute
qu'un seul gagnant ce seul gagnant ce
sera le premier il faut aussi que le
virus ne disparaissent pas or vous savez
qu'il ya un certain nombre de médecins
qui pensent aujourd'hui que le virus va
disparaître avec l'été on a plein
d'exemples comme ça il faut aussi que le
virus ne mute pas sinon le vaccin serait
complètement hawks les sens elle ne
marchait pas l'investissement serait
perdue voyez donc que l'enjeu est quand
même très compliqué qui participe à
cette course au vaccin il ya énormément
de monde il ya elle ya à peu près 70
sous 80 d'entreprises laboratoire qui
aurait développé des projets dans le
monde
vous en avez un bien sûr vous en parliez
un américain la société modern acquis à
rennes on sait faire des tests
dès cette semaine inutile de vous dire
que l'action a explosé en course que ses
créateurs ont déjà fait une immense
fortune et en dehors de cet outsider les
gros gros labos du marché mondial bien
sont en tête
ils sont très connus via glaxo qui le
champion un britannique d'origine
britannique champion de l'antibiotique
le baxo mille c'est lui par exemple il
ya merde finalement qui est un
spécialiste des produits anticancéreux
vous avez failli isr l'américain qui
fait aussi beaucoup de produits
cancéreux mais qui est aussi le
fabricant du viagra
johnson johnson vous avez sanofi pasteur
bien sûr qui est d'origine française
vous avez des américains vous avez des
anglais vous avez un français donc vous
avez un allemand vous avez par ailleurs
deux ou trois chinois alors dans la
perspective de cette bataille on sait
qu'il y à des alliances scientifique
financière vous avez des coups bas aussi
qui se lit sanofi et des laboratoires
américains ce qui a permis aux
américains d'annoncer qu'ils seraient
les premiers servis ça a été démenti
mollement par sanofi jeudi mollement
seulement premier point vous avez une
assez bonne solidarité entre les
chercheurs ça veut dire que tout le
monde va trouver à peu près au même
moment parce que tout le monde se
repassent la formation la question des
droits d'auteur et de redevances ça
viendra ça viendra sans doute
apprécierez liés par des questions
juridiques met le deuxième point il ya
une compétition très fort pour trouver
des capitaux pour trouver des capitaux
ça n'est pas très rentable le vaccin
donc il faut aller chercher les
investisseurs et du coup eh bien on va
aussi chercher des fonds publics
d'où la compétition qui a auprès des
grands laboratoires publics et puis le
troisième point
si on va chercher des fonds publics est
bien une compétition entre les états
pour disposer du vaccin en premier d'où
le travail au niveau européen qui
démarre mais avec un peu de retard on a
vu à un grand gala merkel
emmanuel macron se mettre d'accord sur
des fonds de recherche et des fonds
d'investissement mais il ya aussi
l'annoncé des chinois qui donnerait au
monde leur vaccin ils ont sans doute
beaucoup de choses à se faire pardonner
pour dire une chose pareille
enjeu sanitaire enjeux financiers très
risqués enjeux industriels parce qu'il
faudra bien fabriquer ces milliards de
doses et par conséquent un enjeu
stratégique
c'est un peu comme les masques et comme
les tests alors jean marc
qu'en est-il enfants des populations est
ce qu'ils attendent
plutôt se méfier de ce vaccin écoutez
théoriquement les populations qu'ils
attendent évidemment un vaccin parce que
c'est le seul moyen de se protéger
contre les épidémies
c'est le seul moyen d'éviter tous ces
gestes barrières toutes ces contraintes
la qui pèsent aujourd'hui sur la vie
quotidienne
c'est un vrai problème parce qu'il ya
aussi des gens qui s'en méfient j'allais
dire presque éthiquement presque
scientifiquement les français par
exemple sont terribles le france est le
pays au monde où la population se méfie
le plus des vaccins et le refuse entre
25 et 30% renonçons générale en france à
la vaccination ce qui fait et ce qu'il
fait par exemple que depuis trois ans on
a une reprise des infections de rougeole
et de variole en france la période c'est
quelque chose de redoutables au point où
il a fallu imposer aux parents la
vaccination de leurs enfants obligatoire
sinon il ne rentrait pas à l'école
maternelle c'est une question de santé
publique
mais c'est une question compliquée à
résoudre notamment dans les pays où la
liberté individuelle est sacrée c'est
une question aussi de confiance dans le
système de santé
mais quand on voit la part des français
qui ne respectent pas les gestes
barrière actuellement qui ne respectent
pas ces contraintes c'est cette distance
cesser ces files d'attentes
on est quand même là dans la même
problématique merci beaucoup genre
majeur marc sylvestre pour toutes ces
précisions